si ves a los protones azul y rojo ambos
están unidos a este carbono y si vemos
este doble enlace aquí hay diferentes
grupos unidos a este doble enlace ya que
no hay rotación alrededor del doble
enlace los protones azul y rojo están en
diferentes ambientes por lo que no son
químicamente equivalentes y ya que esos
protones no son equivalentes pueden
emparejarse juntos y ya que esto está
ocurriendo en el mismo carbono llamamos
a esto acoplamiento germinal a ccoo
tú
seminal refiriéndose al hecho de que
ambos protones están en el mismo carbono
y el acoplamiento puede ocurrir esos
protones están lo suficientemente cerca
donde pueden afectarse el uno al otro
primero pensemos en el espectro rm en
donde no hay acoplamiento esperaríamos
una señal para el protón en azul y una
señal para el protón en rojo aquí está
el espectro sin acoplamiento pero
sabemos que el momento magnético del
protón rojo puede tanto alinearse con el
campo magnético externo o en contra del
campo magnético externo y eso hace que
la señal en el protón azul se desdoble
en dos si voy aquí abajo
de hecho veo un 'doblete'
para la señal del protón en azul lo
mismo pasa con el protón en azul
el momento magnético puede tanto
alinearse con el campo magnético externo
o en contra de él y eso desdobla la
señal del protón rojo en un doblete dos
picos
dos picos para la señal del protón rojo
y daré muchos más detalles de esto en el
vídeo del acoplamiento espn espn en este
vídeo nos enfocaremos más en el concepto
de constante de acoplamiento y la
constante de acoplamiento se refiere a
la distancia entre los picos de una
señal si piensas en la distancia entre
los dos picos de esta señal esa es la
constante de acoplamiento y la constante
de acoplamiento es la misma para ambas
señales
porque estos protones están desacoplando
el uno al otro están acoplados juntos la
constante de acoplamiento se mide en
hertz resulta ser 1.4 hertz
y si son 1.4 hertz para ésta debería ser
1.4 g
para esta también porque esos protones
están acoplados juntos la razón por la
cual usamos hertz es porque es la misma
constante de acoplamiento sin importar
cual espectrómetro de rm en estés usando
no importa cuál es la frecuencia de
operación obtendrás la misma constante
de acoplamiento si ves el espectro smn
real aquí está una ampliación de un
fragmento del espectro de rml
la señal para el protón en rojo está
justo aquí
y la señal para el protón el azul está
por aquí así que cuando veo esto cuando
veo el espectro con interacción el
espectro con acoplamiento entre los
protones acabamos de suponer que la
altura de estos dos picos será la misma
pero si ves el espectro de rm n real no
son exactamente las mismas cierto esta
de aquí es un poco más alta y si dibujas
una flecha apuntando al pico más alto
esa flecha apunta a la señal del protón
que está ocasionando el desdoblamiento
esa flecha está apuntando hacia la
derecha y ahí es donde encontramos la
señal para el protón en rojo que está
ocasionando el desdoblamiento del protón
en azul el 'doblete' apunta hacia el
protón con el cual se está acoplando y
lo mismo pasa con esta señal cierto este
pico está un poco más alto
así que dibujamos una flecha apuntando
hacia el pico más alto
y entonces el doblete apunta hacia el
protón con el cual está acoplado y
entonces tienes esta situación donde
obtienes estos dobleces
hay una especie de techo sobre ellos y
puedes imaginar a este techo sobre ellos
de esta manera algunas veces verás esto
en el espectro de rm n y si piensas que
están apuntando hacia el protón con el
cual se acoplan algunas veces pueden
ayudarte cuando intentas entender lo que
está pasando en el espectro de rm n bien
veamos otro ejemplo de constante de
acoplamiento veamos esta molécula y
enfoquémonos en el grupo estilo
por aquí arriba está este carbono que
tiene dos protones esperamos una señal
para esos protones y luego por aquí este
carbono tiene
tres protones esperaríamos otra señal
para estos protones
ahora enfoquémonos en los protones en
azul bien cuántos protones vecinos
tenemos esos protones en azul unidos a
este carbono el carbono vecino es este
cuántos vecinos 1 2 3
tres protones vecinos n es igual a 3 y
usando la regla de n
1 esperamos n más un picos tenemos que
tres más uno es igual a 4 esperaríamos
una señal con cuatro picos esperaríamos
un cuarteto así que déjame continuar y
dibujar eso aquí abajo esperaríamos un
cuarteto para esa señal
esto representa supuestamente lo que
verías en un espectro de rm n
ahora continuamos con los protones en
rojo de aquí cuantos protones vecinos
tienen bueno ambos están unidos a este
carbono y el carbono vecino está aquí y
tenemos dos protones en el carbono
vecino así que tenemos dos vecinos n es
igual a 2 esperaríamos 2 más 1
picos así que tenemos tres picos o un
triple así que déjame ver si puedo
dibujar un triplete aquí
esto sería la señal para estos protones
y aunque los protones rojos y azules se
desacoplan los unos a los otros la
constante de acoplamiento debería ser la
misma la distancia entre los picos
debería ser la misma resulta ser de 7 g
y lo mismo pasa con esta distancia por
lo que esto debe significar que todas
estas son equivalentes y lo mismo pasa
con esta una constante de acoplamiento
de 7 hertz lo mismo pasa con esta señal
cierto esta distancia debería ser 7
hertz y también
espero que esto te dé un primer
acercamiento a la idea de constante de
acoplamiento la cual necesitarás para
entender desdoblamientos mucho más
complejos de los cuales hablaremos en el
siguiente vídeo